le tour de france maintenant avec une
journée un peu folle sur les pavés du
nord
armstrong qui perd du temps chavanel qui
perd son maillot jaune et cancellara qui
redevient le patron a longtemps dit
mathieu even in love qui épique dans
test dans la poussière des pavés du nord
les coureurs du tour ou là un train
d'enfer 13 kilomètres de souffrance
j'en peux plus ils ont vraiment ils vont
vraiment au bout de ce qu'ils font
chapeau bas respect je le fais pas cet
après midi le grand ménage a bien eu
lieu
plusieurs chutes dont celle de frank
schleck l'un des favoris du tour
la clavicule cassée le champion du
luxembourg abandonne jours de galère
pour le maillot jaune sylvain chavanel
crève deux fois satané pavé le français
en jette son vélo dans le fossé
ce soir chavanel n'est plus en tête de
ce tour ennuis mécaniques plus de
crevaisons par dessus ça m'a pas
avantagé ça c'est sûr elle lance
armstrong dans la tourmente
également victime d'une crevaison
l'américain se bat seul et perd à
l'arrivée 55 secondes sur contador
l'espagnol incapable de suivre le rythme
des meilleurs dans les derniers
kilomètres et aremberg c'est le
norvégien hushovd qui s'imposent
mais la bonne affaire est pour andy
schleck le luxembourgeois reprend de
précieuses secondes sur ses rivaux
pas mal pour moi mais c'est un jeu perdu
mon frère aujourd'hui et une journée
seulement après l'avoir cédé le suisse
cancellara récupère son maillot jaune
cette étape aura tenu toutes ses
promesses